the flu epidemic is suspected of causing
two more deaths sources tell CBS station
WCBS a five-year-old in New York had
flu-like symptoms before she died
Saturday and 24-year old Janet Lee bird
insky from Las Vegas died from the flu
last week she reportedly visited doctors
five times for help our doctor Tara
Narula is here with more Tara good
morning good morning bianna more people
are being hospitalized with the flu this
season than any time since the CDC began
keeping track just last week deaths from
influenza and pneumonia were responsible
for about one out of every 10 deaths in
the u.s. she's fine she's doing
everything she needed to do was going to
work we're getting ready for a family
cruise early last week Sabrina Clark
began experiencing flu-like symptoms
according to her husband Steve
she came down woke me up in the morning
said she thinks she must go to the
hospital because she's been coughing up
blood all night Clark says doctors in
Utah diagnosed the normally healthy
mother of two with influenza B and strep
throat he says she died last Tuesday we
asked the doctors that and we said we've
done to prevent it and you know the flu
shot and that what she caught the flu
shot wouldn't stop the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention which
monitors the influenza virus says the
rate of flu-related hospitalizations is
approaching the highest amount on record
several more weeks of increased flu
activity could continue before the
epidemic begins to subside says the
CDC's Acting Director dr. Ann shook it
if things continue like they are right
now we will have even more
hospitalizations this year to help stop
people from getting sick researchers
from Columbia University are
recommending hospitals use special
ultraviolet light panels the lamps can
kill the virus while still remaining
safe around people at Washington
Regional Medical Center in Arkansas UV
robots are already being used to
sterilize patient rooms it's an added
layer of protection for our patients to
ensure that they have the safest place
they can come researchers are constantly
examining new ways to combat the flu a
Japanese drug maker says it has
developed a pill that can kill the virus
within a day
but until that's approved for use here
in the US the flu vaccine and washing
your hands remain the best lines of
defense nor interim thank you